hey I carnellow or however you say that  we've been stabbing at it for a while  and nobody's come up with a better name  than that congratulations on your  retirement for the motorcycle shop and  your new career as a photographer  semakin Jack that's what they call them  and the women clients that he had used  to no one know if he was going to spank  them but he's not he's going to smack  them which nobody likes if you want to  be spanked you got to go next door to  spanking jacks I remember we met in  Indiana on your 25th birthday and I'm  looking forward to seeing you again  sometime man thank you very much for  being a fan jack take care